this story that really captured the
attention of so many people around the
world for the last several days now
reaching this tragic conclusion when the
U.S Coast Guard confirming that they
found the debris of the missing Titan
now they will be collecting some of that
debris over the coming 24 to 48 hours to
bring it up to the surface to analyze it
as part of a wider investigation to try
to figure out how exactly this happened
and perhaps how to prevent it in the
future now this all comes as late
Thursday the U.S Navy confirming that a
Top Secret acoustic detection system
that they have out at Sea actually
picked up some sounds similar to what
would have been an implosion on Sunday
near where the Titan went missing now in
hindsight perhaps those sounds that the
Navy heard then they are saying perhaps
were from perhaps the Titan
five days into the search for the Titan
submersible the news everyone had been
dreading was finally confirmed
this morning
an ROV or remote operated vehicle from
The Vessel Horizon Arctic discovered the
tail cone of the Titan submersible
approximately 1600 feet
from the bow of the Titanic on the sea
floor
the ROV subsequently
found additional debris
in consultation with experts from within
the unified command the debris is
consistent with the catastrophic loss
of the pressure chamber the debris was
only a few hundred meters from the
wreckage of the Titanic a tragic end for
the families of the five men on board
Ocean Gate the owner of the Titan
released a statement confirming the news
saying in part these men were true
explorers who shared a distinct Spirit
of adventure and a deep passion for
exploring and protecting the world's
oceans our hearts are with these five
souls and every member of their families
during this tragic time
with the mystery of what happened to the
Titan now resolved the questions move on
to other things like how exactly was
this allowed to happen who's responsible
and should safety standards for risky
deep sea Expeditions such as this be
changed
since the Titan went missing on Sunday
many concerns have been raised about the
vessel's construction and maintenance
parts of the submarine that I'd seen in
the testing in the Bahamas just seemed a
bit shoddy but what really did it for me
was
um they flatly refused to get any
problem certification and it seemed that
they had no intention of getting any
certification for going down to those
debts once let alone
um several times
questions also likely to be raised about
the enormous cost of the international
operation and whether taxpayers will end
up putting the bill for the search
efforts for bodies that may now never be
recovered
now there's always going to be those
people that want to push the limits or
push the boundaries of exploration
whether it be going to outer space or
the deepest depths of the ocean I think
probably what this tragedy has shown is
that perhaps there needs to be more
regulation or safety standards when it
comes to deep sea exploration those are
a lot of the questions now being asked
on how is this allowed to happen why and
what can be done about it in the future
but it's also going to be very
complicated because where this took
place is hundreds of kilometers out at
Sea in some of the most remote areas of
international waters
Gabriel ozondo Al Jazeera Boston